you may have noticed i am not in japan
you are correct congratulations for
those who don't know me and marsha have
been trying to move to japan now
for quite a while
uh even just make oh god wow
even just making the choice to move
there was really difficult we obviously
would be leaving everything that we
built here behind all these amazing
friends but we just felt like we really
wanted to take on on this adventure
while we're still young
just getting the preliminary visa just
that was a huge process but it didn't
matter because we wanted to go so badly
i counted all the emails with with the
correspondence and it's 700 emails like
we're not able to enter because japan
has been kept their border close for
everyone uh even people going through a
visa process during this most of this
time at least and you know there's
obviously because of covet and that's
the reason why i avoided making a video
even talking about this usually i i
share what's going on with you guys but
it just felt like uh i don't think the
world needs someone who's
you know well off complaining how covet
is affecting them and it's also a
complicated issue and i just felt like
this is going to complicate it more if i
talk about it uh and i don't want to
read a bunch of headlines i can already
see them like pewdiepie complains about
not being able to enter japan i get it
it sounds entitled but at this point i
just wanted to give an update and sort
of talk about what we've been through
these past two years because it's kind
of driving me a bit crazy
uh i think i bothered my friends and
family about this like 600 times and
like what what do you think i should do
hey by the way what do you think i
should do
okay um because every day i swear at
this point because it's been so long
first year was fine whatever
every day i go from
we should just give up this is
ridiculous like it shouldn't have taken
this long you know maybe it just wasn't
meant to be they're not giving us any
updates on when they're planning to
reopen
you know why should they change their
mind all the sudden it's obviously what
if it takes another two years
like we can't just wait forever and then
we go from that to we spent three years
all this money where all these things
we're gonna go we wanna
and i just jump in between that every
single day and it's it's awesome it's
great and that's the thing like i feel
like i'm living a cautionary tale and i
don't know what the meaning behind it is
is it never give up or is it don't give
up because you never know how close you
are i wish i knew this is the hardest
choice i ever made and i don't know one
of the most difficult part about this
whole thing has been not knowing if i
knew that they were going to be close
for two years then at least we could
have made some choices around that we
could have made trips to see our family
more we could have not stayed in my
office for two years we thought we'd be
here for a couple months max
we could have avoided playing this
guessing game of oh the olympics that
surely they're gonna open up for the
olympics they're gonna have to have an
audience okay no um
maybe maybe now the cases are really low
uh and they weren't giving any updates
it's just like maybe next month okay
well maybe next month maybe next month
and maybe next month and do that 24
times it's like
maybe this is my fault for being so
crazy about it but it is a big choice to
make when you make the choice to move to
another country and it's hard to get
just droplets and as it turns out i'm
not alone in this situation uh there was
a new york times article estimating
about 350 000 people stuck in this limbo
situation the same as i am not people
entering with business visa like i am
but
students as well who have already paid
their tuition but they're not allowed in
just want to make it clear like it's not
tourists it's not people going ah
they're still closed
guess i'll have to re schedule my flight
again you know it it's people who made
this difficult choice and and they don't
even have a choice at this point of then
having to wait and honestly reading
their stories online because a lot of
them have been trying to contact me and
send me messages it breaks my heart
because if this has been heavy for me i
can't imagine for
all these people and
i'm honestly just so sorry now that they
closed the border for everyone in
december i think that was the last straw
for a lot of people
seeing messages of people giving up
it's just so sad and another sad part is
like all these people riding me that are
in this limbo situation are hoping that
i'm gonna like urge on the japanese
government of like
do something but they just closed down
for everyone like even not now not even
japanese people can
accident return you know people that
were hoping to see their family abroad
can't do that now and sucks for everyone
so you know obviously it's not gonna
matter if i talk about it that's just
not the case and i guess that's the
point people are so desperate that their
their last hope is literally some
swedish youtuber complaining online
which i'm sorry i'm not even doing i
just wanted to explain my situation i
will say it has been frustrating also
seeing that other japanese people can
travel to other countries as they want
but
their own borders have been closed for
everyone this entire time
kind of like that's no one else talking
about this should am i the one am i the
only one saying this shouldn't countries
like call this out i don't know if i'm
allowed to show it but i am approved to
go for five years which is amazing uh i
would love that but i'm not allowed in
but as part part of me acquiring this i
had to get an office in japan do you
know how hard it is to get an office in
japan if you're not even allowed to
enter the country well thanks to our
friends sir we were able to do it this
is part of our visa we had to have that
i have a company in japan a business
ready to set up i'm going to pay my
taxes whatever i have an employee in
japan i have a house in japan i'm
approved to go but i'm not allowed in
and it's like damn
we're still here huh i keep meeting
people here and they're like you're
still here and it's like yep still here
i don't know what to tell you
i'm almost like sorry for even making
this video it feels it just feels super
lame i don't like talking about this it
feels like i'm complaining and i feel
entitled
but you know i appreciate being able to
talk about my situation and i hope that
other people in my same situation can
find some comfort that you're not alone
and japan if you can give an update at
least
a lot of people would appreciate it and
that was it for my update still not in
japan but
i'll be fine and i'm happy either way so
thank you for listening that's it bye